jeez you speak the true truth criming
Cloud Atlas
what's Cloud Atlas oh it's possible
infinite timelines infinite
possibilities including a timeline where
Jerry's a movie star look you guys are
getting excited about the wrong aspect
of this device what look at this
hello Internet
welcome to film theory the Crumlin
certified swifty a show on the web
oh yeah you gotta get with me but you
know what's decidedly not swifty that we
still have months to wait before we can
feast our eyes on season three of one of
the best shows on TV right now
Rick and Morty man if only I could get
my hands on Rick's portal gun and travel
to an alternate dimension where the
episodes are already out actually come
to think of it if I had a portal gun I'd
probably use it for other things a lot
of attractive women there Morty they all
wanted time with me one of the reasons I
love this show so much is how it's
always dropping really smart nerdy jokes
about reality science and philosophy but
isn't above some good old-fashioned
toilet humor let's prick no you can't
you late Morty the holes opening no Rick
you stinker there's just a lot more
where that came from - ah the classic
fart joke but it's the characters in
Rick and Morty that are the best
elements of the show Jerry's
soul-crushing mediocrity Morty's endless
sexual frustration summers endless quest
to be popular and Beth's domestic
alcoholism actually that last one
probably shouldn't be funny but it is
then of course there's Rick the
enigmatic interdimensional genius the
end of season two leaves us with a
cliffhanger that promises some kind of
revelation about Rick's past and that is
what we're theorizing about today
without getting too specific I'm gonna
go ahead and warn you all now do not
watch any further if you haven't seen up
through season two of Rick and Morty
check obligatory spoiler alert off the
to-do list and let's go the fan
community for the show has been losing
their minds about Rick getting jailed at
the end of season two's finale
how is he gonna get out is season three
gonna start with an epic Prison Break a
la Prison Break style but the biggest
question of all is what did Rick even do
to get locked up in the first place not
much is known about the circumstances
surrounding his imprisonment I mean in
the past he's made some passing
statements about having a lot of enemies
and you know Morty I've got a lot of
enemies in the universe to consider my
genius of threat galactic terrorists a
few subgoal active dictators most of the
entire intergalactic
government wherever you find people with
heads up their asses and at bird
person's wedding he graces Beth with
some casual wedding chatter the road
your father and I walked together is
soaked deeply with the blood of both
friends and enemies must be nice then
right before the vows are given it turns
out summers friend Tammy is an
undercover narc for the Galactic
Federation and her wooing of birdperson
was all just an elaborate ruse to trap
Rick and throw him into the big house
and that's it
that's all we know we don't really know
the specifics of why rick is labeled as
a terrorist it's widely accepted that
the show's creators are withholding the
answers to these questions waiting until
the new episodes come out to reveal the
specifics about Rick's mysterious past
but screw that why wait for them what if
the answer to Rick's misdeeds are right
in front of us already hang on to your
head hats because I'm about to show you
what I got cuz honestly I think I got it
all figured out first here's a clip from
the season two finale and what are you
in for everything
I don't think Rick is being dismissive
here Rick is in prison because he hasn't
just broken laws he's broken entire
systems of laws and the realities that
Harvard that Rick is labeled a terrorist
and thrown into prison because he is
literally a serial destroyer of worlds
that's my theory anyway does it sound
like a stretch it's not for a prime
example of Rick's nonchalant world
destroying antics we only need to look
at the end of the infamous episode Rick
potion number nine it goes like this
Morty realizes it's gonna take a lot
more than an evening of Netflix and
chill to get Jessica to be his
girlfriend so he asks Rick to broome a
love potion when the potions effects
accidentally spread to the entire town
Rick's attempted a cure doesn't quite go
as planned the entire town gets
transformed into classic 80s horror
movie nightmares and after another
failed attempt at a cure the whole world
becomes infected so what a Rick and
Morty do he finds a dimension that is
exactly like his current dimension save
for two things one the attempt to cure
the world of the virus is successful and
two the Rick and Morty of that
respective universe are seconds away
from death that way Rick and Morty from
the infected reality you can simply bury
the bodies of the deceased Rick and
Morty take their place and go on with
their lives know you might be thinking
that this is a really contrived solution
to the show's problem it's awfully
convenient that a reality exists in
which everything is the same except for
those two variables I mean what are the
chances that such a reality would even
exist well according to the Canon of the
show the odds are practically a hundred
percent there's an infinite number of
realities Morty let me explain
the series Rick and Morty appears to
adhere to what's known as Everett's
interpretation of quantum mechanics
better known as the many-worlds
interpretation before many worlds
reality was always viewed as a single
unfolding history a timeline where one
event leads to another leads to the next
Everett's interpretation however
proposed that reality is much less like
a line and more like a tree with
branches a key point for other possible
outcomes are realized to put it simply
everything that could possibly have
happened in our past but didn't has
occurred in the past of some other
universe for instance the other week I
was in the theater and presented with a
dilemma a bag of perfectly good
corn on the ground my moral quandary do
I eat that seemingly perfectly good bag
of Flor corn or do I leave the floor
corn where it belongs on the floor I
even posted the debate on Twitter in the
comments ranged despite my better
judgment and the popular vote I decided
to give the floor corn a pass but by the
many-worlds interpretation there's a
universe where I ate that floor corn and
suffer the consequences of that decision
whether it was reveling an artificial
buttery goodness or getting the herb
well floor corn aside the same is true
for Rick and Morty in the show there's a
universe where Rick decides to make the
love potion for Morty turning the world
into chaos and one where he doesn't and
life goes on as normal so virtually
every reality exists then Rick can
dimension hop as much as he wants
leaving behind destroyed old realities
and inhabiting new ones that conform to
whatever condition he desires and as you
can imagine
Rick jumping from one universe branch to
another whenever it suits him is messing
with the order of those Otherworld
for instance if Rick and Morty are
supposed to be dead in this new
dimension they hop to in Rick potion
number 9 their arrival from the
Cronenberg universe is throwing a whole
new set of variables into an otherwise
closed system and that's going to create
problems to the order of this many world
system which begs the question how many
times has Rick done this if we look back
at the end of Rick potion number nine
Rick seems oddly nonchalant about the
whole of burying his own dead body thing
while Morty has a mind melting
existential crisis Rick just grabs a
beer and watches some TV it's clear that
this is not his first time at the rodeo
he's done this before as a matter of
fact in the very first scene of the
entire show Rick destroys another world
don't remember let's take a look in the
cold open to the pilot Rick drunkenly
attempts to nuke the entire world in
order to allow a fresh start
even though morty eventually talks him
out of it rick passes out before he can
disarm the bomb the countdown sequence
gets closer and closer to launch and we
hear that the bomb is fully armed right
before the show takes us to the title
sequence but what happened that the
show's creators aren't showing us
there's no way morty who's characterized
as naive and not brilliant could
you're out how to stop the launch
sequence himself so boom the show opens
with Rick's favorite drunken pastime
destroying an entire reality I mean if
this is the kind of guy who had burned
down his entire brick-and-mortar startup
just because he got bored there's little
doubt he'll also destroy entire worlds
when they start to tire on him maybe
that's what the devil was referring to
when he said this in the episode
something Ricky I mean seriously I may
be the devil but your grandpa is the
devil we really have no way of telling
just what dimension we're in or how many
times rick has hopped realities heck
every time a new episode starts we could
be in an entirely new dimension how
about all the societal disillusionment
brought up by the Kremlin's and get
schwifty entire faiths are dismantled
due to the giant floating things in the
sky that almost destroy the entire world
yet we see no remnants of the headus
religion in any episodes that follow
that's because that reality was left
behind in between episodes it's clear
that Rick does a fair amount of
interdimensional travel in between
episodes as evidenced by the scan on his
portal gun in close Rick counters of the
Rick kind who's to say that he comes
back to the same reality every time in
all likelihood we're seeing a different
reality almost every time but matpat
you're probably saying he has to be in
the same dimension throughout the show
because he's referred to as earth rick
c-137 c-137 of course referring to the
dimension he resides in well the
prevailing wisdom is that the episodes 1
through 6 of season 1 take place in
dimension c-137 and after Rick and Morty
Cronenberg the world up in Rick potion
number 9 he travels to another unnamed
dimension but what makes us so sure that
the initial dimension we're watching is
c-137 if we think back to some of the
details given to us throughout the
series some things just don't add up for
one were taught that Rick left path for
20 years before he moved into the garage
and re-entered her life getting close
Rick counters of the Rick kind we see
some of Rick's memories projected onto
the screen one of them is holding baby
Morty but that doesn't make sense if
rick has been gone for 20 years and
Morty is still in high school then how
could he be present from Morty's infancy
if earth rick c-137 s memories indicate
a different history than the Beth of the
initial dimension there's no way that
episode 1 through 6 took place in c-137
truth
rick has hopped to and from so many
dimensions he doesn't even remember what
to mention he's in anymore
in the episode Morty night run Rick and
Morty dropped Jerry off at a daycare
specially designed to keep Jerry's busy
while their Rick's and Morty's are often
their irresponsible adventures now
what's telling here is that when Rick is
filling out the admissions paperwork you
write c-137 for his own dimension
but n/a for Jerry's strange detail right
no obviously this Jerry doesn't exist in
a paradoxical non dimension he's from
somewhere so why does Rick write not
applicable here
because Rick destroys and switches
realities so often that he isn't even
sure which one he's in at the moment but
the kicker for me is the show's intro in
the final shot of the awesome opening
sequence we see a visual reference to H
P Lovecraft's Cthulhu a giant cosmic
entity that's so widely known as the
destroyer of worlds
so what's most interesting to me about
this particular moment is that most of
the other clips in the series intro are
later revealed in the context of a full
episode this clip isn't anywhere to be
found in any episode in either season
one or season two so Y included
especially considering it takes up the
much revered spot as the image that
takes us to the title card well it's not
a mistake dear viewers it's a deliberate
reference to Rick the world destroying
terrorist who fancies himself a cosmic
deity he has the power to save or
destroy entire worlds and he is the
reason I'm alive at all but hey that's
just a theory of film theory and cut if
you want more schwifty Rick and Morty
action click here to check out my
friends at wisecrack and their video on
the philosophy of Rick and Morty if you
like this video you'll love that one
covering everything from cosmic body
word to Jerry being the everyman
and finally before you go aim your
portal gun right here to subscribe to
the film theorists why would you do that
well duh for more cool videos like this
you made it this deep into the video so
you must have really liked it so why not
keep the notifications coming I mean
next episode is gonna be all about a
Marvel movie that I think everyone's
really excited about so if you want to
subscribe to make sure that that one
winds up in your feed it wouldn't be a
bad idea
just sayin make the smart call subscribe